We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
Our caller today has identified another bit
of hypocrisy from the right wing.
Take a listen to this.
Hey, David.
Hey, after all of these right wing protests
where they're blocking traffic, stopping nurses
from getting to hospital.
Right.
All our stuff.
Can these right wing lunatics who love to
say that wherever the left as this celestials,
they blog traffic or Stirling's protest, all
this stuff can can they are shut and never,
ever, ever again say that this is this is
for lives.
This is a.
Yeah.
So, listen, you're absolutely right.
And there's actually a bigger hypocrisy.
So first of all, the right often likes to
say, you know, these left with no job.
They'll they'll Brock block traffic.
They prevent people who need to get to work
from getting to work, get a job, losers or
let L.R.A.
Right.
You know that now they are blocking traffic.
They are preventing ambulances from getting
to hospitals to get people care because they
are protesting the lockdown orders.
But there's a bigger hypocrisy.
It is these supposed law and order right wingers
who love to say obey authority, obey authority.
And yet here the authorities, medical and
political, are saying, stay the hell home.
This is dangerous.
Wear a mask, social distance.
Now they say obey authority.
These are oppressive people who have declared
themselves kings.
The hypocrisy is bigger than just the blocking
traffic, my friend.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Don't miss it.
Get instant access by signing up at goign
packman dot.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.